die dann schauen wir auf den nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt da geht es um das 9
euro ticket und man könnte das als
kompliment der linksfraktion an die
bundesregierung verstehen denn die
linksfraktion möchte in einem antrag
dass das neue euro ticket verlängert
wird bis 20 23 und das ab dann 20 23
also ab nächsten jahr 1
365 euro ticket pro jahr
eingeführt wird also für einen euro pro
tag oder für 365 euro pro jahr denn das
neun euro ticket noch einmal zur
erinnerung
gibt es ja im juni juli und august für
jeweils 9 euro können die besitzerinnen
und besitzer eines solchen tickets im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr
fahren dieses ticket stößt bisher auf
großen zuspruch besonders samstags
sind die zug reisen im schnitt im juni
um 83 prozent gestiegen im vergleich zum
vorkrisenniveau das ist natürlich um die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu entlasten
aufgrund der gestiegenen energiepreise
gibt es ja doch sehr viele menschen die
das auch im portemonnaie spüren und das
war dann eine idee
die menschen hier zu unterstützen jetzt
wird janine wissler als erstes zu diesem
antrag ihrer fraktion sprechen sie ist
ja auch parteichefin der linken
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
seit juni gibt es das neue euro ticket
und die nachfrage zeigt wie groß der
bedarf nach einem bezahlbaren pnv ist
anders als der riesen flop tank rabatt
ist das nämlich eine wirkliche
entlastung für die menschen und
ermöglicht bundesweite mobilität viele
menschen mit wenig geld für zum ersten
mal seit jahren wieder weit weg wohnende
verwandte und freunde besuchen familien
werden von den teuren monatskarten
entlastet 21 millionen tickets wurden
allein im ersten monat verkauft es gab
weniger staus und die zufriedenheit ist
nach angaben des verkehrsministerium mit
89 prozent sehr hoch und das obwohl die
bahn das angebot angesichts der erhöhten
nachfrage kaum ausgeweitet hat und hier
meine damen und herren besteht
dringender nachholbedarf zum vergleich
in der schweiz werden jährlich mehr als
400 euro pro einwohner für die
schieneninfrastruktur
aufgewendet in deutschland sind es
gerade mal 120 euro und das bedeutet
dass eben viele bahnreisende durch
verspätungen zugausfälle und überfüllte
regionalzüge täglich genervt sind und
verspätet ankommen die
regionalisierungsmittel meine damen und
herren müssen dringend erhöht werden
fordert auch die
verkehrsministerkonferenz
stillgelegte bahnstrecken müssen
reaktiviert werden unternimmt die raum
besser angebunden werden denn ein
günstiges ticket hilft den menschen
nichts wenn kein bus fährt was wir
brauchen ist ein barrierefreien pnv und
zwar sowohl baulich als auch preislich
gut getaktet und verlässt
angesichts des erfolgs des neuen euro
tickets ich weiß gekommen sich so
aufregen ich lobe 49 euro ticket und
angesichts dieses erfolges wurde ja
jeder vernünftige verkehrsminister darum
kämpfen dass es fortgesetzt wird nicht
aber verkehrsminister wissing fdp er und
finanzminister lindner haben ja schon
ausgeschlossen dass das ticket
verlängert wird mit der begründung es
sei zu teuer während man
mineralölkonzernen extragewinne mit dem
tank rabatt zuschuss hat und da passiert
im verantwortungsbereich eines fdp
geführten ministeriums ausnahmsweise mal
was sinnvolles und dann soll
ausgerechnet das beerdigt werden meine
damen und herren das versteht doch kein
mensch wenn du denn eure ticket ein
erfolg war und deswegen brauchen wir
eine anschlussregelung der
verkehrssektor ist die große
achillesferse beim klimaschutz wir
müssen dort dringend die fahrgastzahlen
erhöhen und deswegen schlagen wir vor
dass es neun euro ticket bis zum
jahresende in dieser form verlängert
wird und diese zeit sollten wir nutzen
um eine vernünftige regelung zu finden
dauerhaft für günstige preise und
einfache tarife das sollte zunächst das
1 euro tickets seien nämlich einen euro
am tag und als linke fordern wir zudem
dass die nutzung von bus nun waren
mittelfristig zum nulltarif möglich ist
das neuro theke zeigt wie nv geht auch
bezahlbar ergeht auch unkompliziert die
kleinstaaterei der verkehrsverbünde
wurde kurzzeitig überwunden tarifzonen
waren und automaten hinfällig hinter
dieser errungenschaften damen und herren
zu regel noch nicht mehr zurückfallen so
internet ab in diesem sinne freie fahrt
für freie bürger rinnen und bürger und
anders als die fdp meinen wir damit
nicht das recht zum hafen sondern wir
meinen bezahlbare mobilität für alle
pilger
janine wissler hat hier die debatte
eröffnet nach dieser debatte wird dieser
antrag erst einmal in den
verkehrsausschuss überwiesen wir sehen
aber gerade gar kein vertreter aus dem
verkehrsministerium
committee martin spricht jetzt für die
spd-fraktion wochen ganz deutlich
gezeigt die menschen in deutschland die
farbe wurst und wagen sie fahren auch
gern bis zum wagen und das neun euro
ticket das ist allen unkenrufen vor
allem von dieser seite des parlaments
aus das ist ein großer erfolg und es
wirkt als teil eines umfangreichen
entlastungspaket mit ganz vielen
weiteren maßnahmen für die bürgerinnen
bürger meine damen und herren
und erste zwischenergebnisse jahr die
zeiten auch schon die zahl der
verkauften tickets wurde schon genannt
dass vermehrt grad pendlerinnen und
pendler in den klimafreundlichen öpnv
umsteigen ich finde das ist eine gute
nachricht
und was auch gut ist dass die leute die
gesellschaft eigentlich so viel wie noch
nie wie ich es noch nie erlebt habe
überreden auf einmal ist das in aller
munde und alle interessieren sich dafür
und auch das ist gut und den hat diesen
rückenwind in wissen jetzt auch nutzen
für unsere diskussion die wir schon
längst führen niveau pnv
weiterentwickeln und wie wir ihn
langfristig ich sag noch mal das wort
ist langfristig verbessern und stärken
können und das wollen wir das haben wir
auch einen koalitionsvertrag ganz klar
festgehalten und das geht gemeinsam mit
ländern kommunen und auch den
verkehrsverbünden in der gemeinsamen
verantwortung
und die antrag werte frau wissler und
kollegen von den linken der ist so
jenseits von realpolitik unterstellt man
bei ihren forderungen ja auch immer
wieder fest sie fordern sehr viel aber
die finanzierung die man braucht dafür
auch die diskussion mit ihren
kolleginnen kollegen verordnen ländern
wo sie auch verantwortung tragen die
kamera dann lesen wenn man sich mal
anschaut in welcher herausforderung in
laage wir gerade sind auch die länder
auch die verkehrsunternehmen stehen vor
steigenden energiepreisen die bezahlt
werden müssen weil es drohen wirklich
real abbestellung von verkehrenden
einigen regionen und ja natürlich wollen
müssen die auch die kapazität ausbauen
gerade in mittelzentren gerade in
ländlichen räumen da bringt mir auch ein
günstiges ticket nur begrenzt was und
natürlich werden wir auch über
ticketpreise reden müssen aber all das
muss eben auch realisierbar sei mit
einer vernünftigen grundlage und das
fehlt bei ihrem antrag komplett
und natürlich ja auch das und wird sich
weiter finanziell engagieren auch mit
einer erhöhung der
regionalisierungsmittel aber das sage
ich ganz deutlich auch länder und
kommunen müssen ihren teil der
finanziellen verantwortung tragen öpnv
ist ein gemeinschaftsprojekt liebe
kollegin kollegen und wir arbeiten ja
bereits an dem ausbau modernisierungs
pakt mit den ländern die neben omv zudem
verkehrsmittel der zukunft zu machen
denn wenn wir die ziele einhalten wollen
brauchen wir mehr frauen natürlich mit
mehr fahrgästen wenn die aufgabe der
daseinsvorsorge ernst nehmen wollen dann
brauchen wir verlässliche öpnv und auch
wenn wir teilhabe sichern wollen
brauchen wir über ev der für alle
zugänglich ist und jetzt gehts eben
darum dass man gemeinsam einen klaren
plan hat jemand angeboten
qualitätsstandards definiert definiert
öpnv in ländlichen räumen mittelzentren
stärkt digitalisierung barrierefreiheit
vernetzte mobilität vor allem
tarifsysteme vereinfacht und natürlich
ja das hat uns das man eure tickets
gezeigt werden jetzt auch über
ticketpreise reden und ich habe
das große ziel
das bus und bahn fahren so einfach wird
die auto fahren und genau das finde ich
ist das große erfolgserlebnis dieses
tickets nämlich die einfachheit die
bundesweite gültigkeit kann tarif stimme
mehr keine unsicherheit mehr wenn man
irgendeine tarif grenze überschreitet
was man ja gar nicht mitgekriegt und
kein verzweifelter mehr am
ticketautomaten also quasi einsteigen
fahren aussteigen und gut ist und genau
diesen weg das ist der wollen wir weiter
arbeiten müssen und so kann die zukunft
von öpnv rauth aussehen und wir haben
jetzt auch türen geöffnet die lange
verschlossen blieben auch bei ländern
und auch bei verkehrsverbünden und da
muss es jetzt weitergehen deutschland
hat 16 bundesländer deutschland hat über
60 tarif und verkehrsverbünde wir müssen
diese kleinstaaterei am fahrgast vorbei
abschaffen ziel ist es das wäre
wünschenswert eine vision eine
revolution ein land ein ticket zu einem
machbaren preis lassen sie uns daran
gemeinsam arbeiten dass wir an
durchbruch für einen zukunftsfähigen
öpnv ich danke ihnen
dorothee martin war das für die
spd-ministerin ass michael bont er sitzt
für die cdu csu fraktion im
verkehrsausschuss im deutschen bundestag
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
in wenigen tagen wird der vdv die erste
zwischenbilanz zum neuen euro ticket
ziehen er machte die erhebungen und
untersuchungen im auftrag und ich bin
mir sicher dass der ausreichend material
für zahlreiche jubelmeldungen aus den
ampel fraktionen hergeben wird unter den
tisch fallen wird aber in diesen presse
statements ganz sicher dass wenn man
sich die zahlen genau anschaut auch
zahlreiche menschen in deutschland beim
neuen euro ticket auf der strecke
geblieben sind die schere zwischen stadt
und land zeigt sich auch in der nutzung
dieses billig angebots während sich das
ticket in berlin vornehmlich in der
nutzung für freizeitverkehr großer
beliebtheit erfreut bleibt auf dem land
bei mir auf der alb die
begeisterung völlig aus denn völlig
überraschend wird auch dort für neun
euro im monat kein einziger bus mehr die
antwort auf diese problematik ist
eigentlich allen fraktionen im haus
bekannt wir brauchen mehr fahrzeuge wir
brauchen mehr personal dichtere takte
attraktivere modernere angebote und das
gerade in der fläche
aber das kostet geld und dieses geld hat
man eben jetzt prioritär er in ein
billig ticket gesteckt als es dort
einzusetzen wo es im öpnv auch dringend
benötigt wird und ich muss schon sagen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
wundere mich etwas über ihren antrag
eine pauschale ticket subventionierung
mit der gießkanne stadt zielgerichteter
entlastung von sozial schwachen und was
mit den nutzerinnen und nutzern auf dem
land passiert ist ihm auch egal denn
jeder der sich mit dem öpnv in
deutschland auskennt weiß die beiden
forderungen in ihrem antrag nämlich
billigtickets und gleichzeitiger ausbau
passen einfach nicht zusammen oder
oder um es auf den punkt zu bringen auf
die frage woher das geld für ihre
vorschläge kommen soll denken sie nicht
weiter als bis zur bundesdruckerei und
dabei ignorieren sie wieder einmal die
wirtschaftlichen zusammenhänge
denn auch die leistungserbringer des
öpnv fahren ihre busse bahnen taxis
nicht aus purem idealismus
die beschäftigten müssen auch in dem
zeiten steigender preise ihrer familien
ernähren können den unternehmen steht
schon allein aufgrund der antriebs wende
erhebliche investitionen bevor und unser
lohn schraube wollen sie ja obendrein
noch drehen und das besonders ironische
an den derzeitigen hilfsmaßnahmen ist ja
eigentlich das vom tank rabatt die nv
unternehmen viel viel weniger
profitieren als der private autofahrer
mit seinem diesel oder benzin fahrzeug
meine damen und herren in wenigen wochen
werden sämtliche hilfsmaßnahmen der
bundesregierung
auslaufen was dann folgt ist das böse
erwachen bei allen menschen in unserem
land aber vor allem auch im öpnv
erste unternehmen haben
preissteigerungen aufgrund der
gestiegenen ölpreise bereits von rund 14
prozent für die tarife im nächsten jahr
zur genehmigung eingereicht das ist
total fatal für das system des öpnv und
es wird auch unser bundeshaushalt auf
dauer nicht abfedern können wir haben es
in den heutigen reden der koalitionäre
ja schon mehrfach in anderen punkten
gehört
und so nett so nett die idee eines 375
vertreibungen
365 euro tickets für alle auch ist wer
das fordert verkennt vollkommen dass die
unternehmen im öpnv deren mitarbeitern
mitarbeiter mit enormen zusätzlichen
kraftanstrengungen von juni bis august
den öffentlichen verkehr auch ein stück
weit auf verschleiß fahren um den
zusätzlichen fahrgäste vor allem in den
touristischen verkehren zu befördern bei
einer fortsetzung bis zum jahresende
haben sie die linke nichts anderes
erreicht als unternehmen am rande des
ruins und mitarbeiter im dauer
krankenstand das geld muss zuerst in den
op en v gesteckt werden bevor wir die
tickets und die taschen der nutzer damit
subventionieren in einem föderalen
steuer danke wunderbares beispiel in den
letzten jahren hatten das geld ich
schaue auf die kollegen aus der letzten
koalition haben wir das geld für den etv
hochgefahren wie keine andere regierung
zuvor das darf noch die übrigens auch
erwähnen danke für den zwischenruf aber
auch es liegt nicht allein am preis der
tickets sondern die nutzer schätzen ins
gibt insgesamt und insbesondere auch die
durchgängigkeit der tickets dass man
über länder und tarif grenzen hinweg
fahren kann das bestätigt auch der vcd
und riegel hat nämlich ich komme zum
schluss im gegensatz zu ihnen erkannt
dass die vereinheitlichung der tickets
das größte positive element war und auch
wenn wir mit dem vcd nicht immer auf
einer linie sind hier hatte recht da
muss man etwas tun federn
michael bont war das hat der
linksfraktion hier ignoranz der
wirtschaftlichen zusammenhänge
vorgeworfen aufgrund des antrags zur
verlängerung des neuen euro tickets
das ja nur noch bis inklusive august
gelten soll die linksfraktion möchte das
gerne länger machen und nico slavik
jetzt für die grünen
präsidentin sehr geehrte kolleg in liebe
besucher in wie würden wir uns bewegen
wenn wir uns diese bewegung alle
gleichermaßen leisten könnten wohin
würden wir uns bewegen und was wird es
mit uns machen wenn wir räume
gleichermaßen beanspruchen könnten
distanzen gleichberechtigt überwinden
könnten wie würde eine gesellschaft
aussehen in der öffentliche
transportmittel tatsächlich öffentlich
wären und nicht mehr das vorrecht
derjenigen die es sich leisten können
und müssen so lauteten die einleitenden
worte eines instagram chaos zu einem
bild des neuen euro tickets der über
83.000 mal geleitet wurde ich glaube
vielen von uns ist noch nicht
hinreichend bewusst geworden dass wir
mit dem neuen euro ticket etwas
historisches geschaffen haben wir haben
millionen menschen in diesem land mobil
gemacht und diese mobilität zu einem
preis angeboten der für alle bezahlbar
ist wir haben ein angebot geschaffen das
gleichermaßen sozial ist gut fürs klima
und die umwelt und den menschen freiheit
gibt von a nach b zu kommen das neun
euro ticket ist schon jetzt ein
highlight unserer ampelkoalition und die
zahlen sprechen für sich
21 millionen verkaufte ticket allein im
juni weniger stau in 23 von 26
untersuchten städten in berlin 80
prozent weniger menschen ohne fahrschein
erwischt 10 bis 15 prozent mehr menschen
in den zügen der db regio mehr
bahnreisen und dafür weniger
straßenverkehr
deutschland will die verkehrswende und
lassen uns heute einmal feiern dass wir
als politik gezeigt haben dass das
unmögliche möglich werden kann der
gestrige deutschlandtrends hatte zeigt
63 prozent der deutschen wünschen sich
eine fortsetzung des neuen euro tickets
übrigens auch ihre anhänger in bei
cdu/csu jetzt wirken die kritiker innen
wagen acht das ist so teuer wo soll das
geld herkommen
ich hatte da einige ideen lassen sie uns
doch endlich mal über klimaschädliche
subventionen im verkehrsbereich sprechen
beispiel energie steuerbefreiung kerosin
das sind 8,9 milliarden euro im jahr
oder energie steuerbegünstigung für den
dieselkraftstoff das wären 8,4
milliarden im jahr oder wie wäre es mit
einem sondervermögen verkehrswende oder
der finanzierung aus dem klima- und
transformation spawn
viele wege führen nach rom oder in
unserem fall nach sylt weniger meckern
mehr konstruktive lösungen suchen das
ist es was die menschen von uns erwarten
lassen sie uns den sommer nutzen eine
anschlusslösung für das neue euro ticket
zu finden die gespräche finden jetzt
statt wann sonst bekäme der wieder die
möglichkeit etwas zu beschließen was
sozial und klimafreundlich ist und
millionen von menschen mehr freiheit
gibt vielen dank
viele wege führen nach sylt war hier der
spruch das ist jetzt auch immer wieder
zu lesen in seriösen und mittel seriösen
gazetten wäre alles kann sich auf sylt
aufhält
mike monjack spricht jetzt für die
fdp-fraktion er ist obmann im
tourismusausschuss
alle kollegen klick auf
also
business lächeln im gesicht aber das was
sie sagen dass neuen euro ticket ist ein
durchschlagender erfolg und wie sie es
in ihrem antrag geschrieben haben und
behaupten nein das ist es leider nicht
denn verkaufszahlen allein sind noch
lange kein erfolg und gerade das bei den
linken das und mich sehr billig ist
immer ein verlust der qualität und vor
allen dingen auf kosten der mitarbeiter
und des materials
das handelsblatt für der aktion eine
aktion die note schaltung vorteil ist
der preis allein entscheidet nichts wir
können jeden euro wir können jeden
bürger günstige wochenend und feiern und
party ausflüge innerhalb deutschlands
jede finanzielle entlastung ist richtig
und wichtig aber die kosten steigen und
sind da
rot-gelb-grüne ampel politik hilft im
über mv aber keinen einzigen kilometer
weiter es fehlt an infrastruktur an
fahrzeugen und personal kein einziger
bus ist bei mir aus dem ländlichen raum
mehr geformt oder eingesetzt wurden
gerade bot im ländlichen raum muss aber
unsere blick seien nicht nur in den
metropolen nicht nur in berlin und was
sie aufgeführt haben es gibt leute die
leben auf land und
die brauchen ihr auto
welcher berufspendler würden für eine
unzuverlässige bahn oder hören bus das
thema täglich können sein auto stehen
lassen können niemand und keine der
antrag blendet völlig aus dass er noch
in europa scheint vor allem an
wochenenden und ausflüge gegangen ist
nichts ist schlimmer penguins nähe und
das wollten ja die drei milliarden
bewirken und das wurde sehr sogar kein
einziger pendler ist nah dabei hier
hätten sich über treuebonus
staatsmilliarden gefreut die nur
versenken meine damen und herren das
neun euro ticket ist gescheitert sie
hatten ihren herrn schorr mit platz 9
millionen versenkt aber die fdp hat
zweimal die milliarden in die hand
genommen und damit ihre
steuergeldverschwendung hochgetrieben
und dass meine lieben bürger ist die
reale politik
und dieses teure scheidung hoffenheim
klar es ist die sozialistische
planwirtschaft die sie wollen als svp
kraftfutter entsteht und die reichsbahn
und die täter lassen schon mal grüßen
wir sind uns einig vorfall muss dringend
reformiert werden
wie gesagt vor allem im ländlichen raum
das netz und die taktung wurden bei uns
im osten so viel zu sagen gestrichen und
massiv verringern und dafür sind nur sie
alle die hier sitzen die jahrelange
verkehrspolitik gemacht dann die
altparteien verantwortlich
vorschlag zu hören vorschlag von mir die
milliarden die jetzt gerade ohne sinn
und verstand richtig versenkt werden
sind im öpnv in personal
infrastruktur in neue fahrzeuge viel
besser investiert als noch verlängerung
3 millionen sind schon weg und genau das
muss ein av stelle stehen und nicht ran
tritt
erst unfähig und jetzt über foto der
minister dazu könnten noch
sozialistische planwirtschaft und grüne
ideologen das komischste fdp lieber
nichts mache als alles falsch machen
glückauf
an alle bürger schöne und gute reise
aber hoffentlich nicht mit dem funkhaus
überzeugt im flugverkehr was sie da auch
wieder eingerichtet haben sondern können
sie hinnehmen sie noch die drei monate
die zu enthalten die noch das ein oder
andere teil passe gesagt dass nur ein
euro ticket in phase durch deutschland
dann ist es vorbei
monjack wird schon mal schön urlaub der
muss aber noch ein bisschen warten hier
für die abgeordneten so zur cup ist 20
45 uhr wird hier diese debatte noch
laufen bzw
diese sitzung heute
bundestags vizepräsidentin katrin göring
eckardt fragt noch mal ob es noch
mitglieder des hauses gibt die noch
nicht abgestimmt haben
gut also ich
schließe die abstimmung und das glaube
ich jetzt nicht
frau künast hat noch nicht abgegeben
doch
alles durch alles durch und der brust
auch insofern schließt sich jetzt die
abstimmung bis die schriftführerin und
schriftführer mit der auszählung zu
beginnen herzlich also das hier ist noch
mal dann die abstimmung zum
bundeswehr-einsatz in bosnien-
herzegowina die dann jetzt ausgezählt
werden die stimmen wie die abgeordneten
dafür gestimmt haben wir gegen war hier
in der debatte valentin aber ich spreche
jetzt für die fdp fraktion
dafür und der nächste kollege der hier
spricht ist für die fdp-fraktion
valentin aber
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen manchmal passt
glückauf vor allem wenn das niveau der
argumentation unter tage ist ich glaube
besondere situation verlangen besondere
das neue neurotiker ist zweifelsohne so
eine besondere maßnahme es ist aber auch
ein großer erfolg da sehen wir an der
resonanz der menschen es ist vor allem
aber auch 1 es ist eine akute eine
zeitlich befristete entlastungsmaßnahmen
für die menschen in zeiten steigender
energiepreise ich habe mehrmals hier
erwähnen dass es neun euro ticket eine
große chance ist mehr über die
bedürfnisse der nutzerinnen und nutzer
zu erfahren den einen oder anderen
wieder für den öpnv zu interessieren
vielleicht sogar dafür zu begeistern
aber was wir schon jetzt sehen ist dass
das system viel zu lange auf verschleiß
gefahren wurde dass kapazitäten
vernachlässigt wurden und dass wir hier
einen scherbenhaufen geerbt haben wir
stehen vor der gewaltigen aufgabe
unserer op en v system fit für die
zukunft zu machen und die drei
schlagworte die hier nennen möchte sehen
komfortable benutzung für die menschen
digitalisierung und flexibilität daher
ist es wichtig dass wir jetzt schon in
das system investieren das ausbauen mehr
kapazitäten schaffen und ein modernes
angebot anbieten dass die menschen auch
wollen das darf übrigens nicht an zug
und bus türen aufhören das geht an den
bahnhöfen weiter ich denke da an die
länge und breite von bahnsteigen ich
denke an die nach wie vor
unbefriedigende barrierefreiheit das
ändert aber bei banalen fragen die die
vier sitzplätze habe ich an den
bahnsteigen im ländlichen raum haben wir
häufig noch gar kein öl pnv oder nur zu
gewissen kernzeiten die die
lebensrealitäten von menschen gerade
jungen menschen komplett ausklammern und
da muss ich sagen finde ich es schon
irgendwie hohen gegenüber den menschen
im ländlichen raum dass hier der tank
rabatt pauschal als flop abgestempelt
wird er hat in der entlastung der
menschen im ländlichen raum sehr vieles
bewirkt
wir haben aber auch die herausforderung
nicht nur auszubauen qualität zu
verbessern wir müssen uns auch
wirtschaftlichen realitäten stellen und
das heißt wir können jeden euro nur
einmal ausgeben und anstatt in blinde
subventionierung auf die dauer zu gehen
müssen wir in die qualität in die
investition reingehen der bedarf ist
wir haben bei der digitalisierung extrem
große kosten die auf die verbünde zu
kommen wir haben das thema autonomes
fahren das jetzt in die masse ausgerollt
wird wir haben den umstieg auf e
mobilität und damit auf
klimafreundlichkeit wo wir investieren
müssen das sollte priorität haben denn
ich glaube mit diesen investitionen
schaffen wir im system zufriedenheit bei
den nutzerinnen und nutzern und stellen
sicher dass sie nicht nur 12 mal zum
öpnv aufgreifen sondern dass sie
dauerhaft zufriedene kundinnen und
kunden werden
statt also heute
statt also heute vorschnell nach einer
verlängerung zu rufen sollten wir jetzt
wirklich die parallel laufende
evaluation durch den vdv abwarten der
vdv steht wirklich nicht im verdacht im
spnv oder das neun euro ticket künstlich
schlecht rechnen zu wollen wir müssen
wissen wo und welche menschen auf den
öpnv umsteigen schaffen wir die
verlagerung von den verkehr an oder
stellen wir punktuell er eine neu
generierung von verkehren her die wir
nicht wollen wir müssen sicherstellen
dass die kern vorteile dieses neuen euro
tickets die eben nicht nur im preis
liegen sondern die auch ganz
entscheidend von der einfachheit leben
auch volle geltung entfalten können ich
selbst lebe an der grenze von 4
verkehrsverbünden ich weiß wie schwierig
es ist gerade im ländlichen raum von a
nach b zu kommen niemand fliegt durch
wir müssen diesen tarif dschungel für
die nutzerinnen und nutzer licht und das
sehen wir auch beim neuen euro ticket
das wird entgegen genommen
und ein punkt auf den ich nur eingehen
möchte ich glaube es ist nur richtig
menschen nach ihrer leistungsfähigkeit
an den kosten für den öpnv zu beteiligen
warum 736 bundestagsabgeordnete
millionen menschen in den höchsten
steuerklasse die das geld haben die das
geld auch gerne für den öpnv geben ohne
eine bedarfsprüfung ein de facto
sozialticket haben soll ist mir
schleierhaft fair und sozial geht anders
liebe linksfraktion
sprechen wir also lieber über die
gezielte förderung von bedürftigen
menschen den ich jeder zeit mit dabei
das sollten wir machen wir möchten neue
euro ticket das uns erkenntnisse liefert
das uns zeigt was die bedürfnisse der
menschen in den städten im ländlichen
raum ist wie der pnv in zukunft aussehen
muss denn wir wollen keine pnv der nur
billig ist wir wollen ötv- der gut ist
der mobilität in die breite bringen und
der sicherstellt dass menschen auf dauer
den öpnv auch nutzen ich danke ihnen
jeden tag
valentin abel fdp fraktion hat hier
einerseits ist nur ein euro ticket
natürlich gelobt aber auch sich gegen
eine verlängerung ausgesprochen wie
übrigens auch der bundesverkehrsminister
und wir sehen auch hier seine
staatssekretärin daniela klug hat jetzt
die debatte verfolgt auch volker wissing
hat schon gesagt dass es zu teuer ist
das neue neurotiker zu verlängern und
hat auf kosten von über eine milliarde
euro pro monat hingewiesen
ein kleines bisschen für klarheit sorgen
muss zum ersten juni hat die ampel
koalition und ich sage ausdrücklich
maßgeblich als entlastung für die
bürgerinnen und bürger für die
gestiegenen energiepreise und zur
attraktivitätssteigerung natürlich auch
dass nur ein euro ticket eingeführt
dadurch reduzieren sich die kosten
gegenüber regulären monatstickets auf
etwa 10 bis 15 prozent bereits in meinen
letzten reden habe ich hier immer wieder
erläutert dass das für eine vierköpfige
familie einer entlastung von etwa 1000
euro netto sein könnte
damit ist deutlich wir haben es
geschafft mit diesem ticket eine
entlastung
darzustellen für die menschen ende juni
bilanzierte der vdv
21 millionen tickets verkauft worden
ich denke das kann man nicht als
irgendeine banale maßnahme runter reden
dass es eindeutig ein großer erfolg der
die menschen in ihrer kasse entlastet
und inzwischen gibt es auch die ersten
erhebungen die sagen ganz klar 53
prozent der menschen trotz dem hype der
darauf kam nutzen dieses ticket für
alltägliche fahrten 39 prozent fahren
damit tatsächlich zur arbeit zur
ausbildungsstätte zur schule klar 33
prozent nutzen dieses ticket auch für
ausflüge und 14 prozent nutzen dieses
ticket für urlaub und ich sag ihnen
ihren aller deutlichkeit als
berichterstatter der größten fraktion in
diesem haus für dieses thema
dieses ticket kann natürlich auch für
urlaubsfahrten genutzt werden und ich
weiß auch nicht warum uns immer wieder
hier leute erklären wofür dieses ticket
da ist oder düfte nicht wir haben dieses
ticket dafür gedacht menschen zu
entlasten und das kku dieses ticket auch
in diesem land geht es nicht nur darum
zu arbeiten und zu leben es geht auch
darum zu leben
und das muss ihnen klar sein dazu
gehören eindeutig auch ausflüge am
wochenende dazu gehören auch
urlaubsfahrten
medienberichten die ganze zeit vor
völlig überfüllten zügen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen um damit
vielleicht heute mal aufzuräumen ja es
gab überfüllte züge sogar eine ganze
menge aber die die tatsächlich überfüllt
waren das waren lediglich zwei prozent
ich glaube da kann man nicht die ganze
zeit davon reden dass hier alles
überfüllt ist und dass das alles nicht
funktioniert hat und im übrigen
insbesondere an die cdu fraktion vielen
dank für die tolle arbeit in den letzten
jahren und sie berufen sich auch immer
über die massenweise überfüllten züge
nur zur erinnerung
2014 als sie noch den verkehrsminister
gestellt haben hieß es in den zeitungen
zu pfingsten wohlgemerkt bahn ist
komplett überfordert 2009 10 auch an
pfingsten
chaos bei der bahn das liegt daran dass
man über jahre den verkehr nicht
ausgebaut hat und jetzt können sie
natürlich sagen man muss erstmal den
verkehr ausbauen aber im moment haben
die leute nicht genug geld in der kasse
und genau dafür haben wir diese
entlastung gemacht
vielen dank das alles sind themen die
müssen wir jetzt natürlich weiter
besprechen wie kein zweiter gehen was
haben wir noch für möglichkeiten das
machen wir aber gemeinsam mit dem
ländern beim ausbau und modernisierung
packt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
können wir heute nicht einfach so übers
knie brechen abschließen möchte ich noch
sagen ich freue mich dass die
bürgerinnen und bürgern noch knapp zwei
monate dieses tolle ticket nutzen können
ich wünsche ihnen weiter eine gute fahrt
und ich gebe ihnen das ergebnis der
namentlichen abstimmung bekannt es geht
um die beschlussempfehlung des
auswärtigen ausschusses zu dem antrag
der bundesregierung zur wiederaufnahme
der beteiligung bewaffneter deutscher
streitkräfte an der eu-geführten
sicherheitsoperation in bosnien und
herzegowina auf den drucksachen 20 22 42
und 20 26 49 abgegeben wurden 617
stimmen mit ja haben gestimmt 518 mit
996 es gab drei enthaltungen
damit ist die beschlussempfehlung
angenommen herzlichen dank so und das
bedeutet maximal 50 soldatinnen und
soldaten können nach bosnien herzegowina
entsandt werden von der bundesregierung
jonas geissler spricht jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wenn man nach fünf wochen einführung
einer maßnahme die schon bewertet es
sollte eigentlich jedem von uns klar
sein dass das im vorfeld schon eine sehr
gewagte diskussion wird wenn ich ganz
ehrlich sein muss und mehr angehört habe
heute was der ein oder andere von ihnen
gesagt hat stelle ich fest dass jeder im
endeffekt die gleichen narrativer
erzählt hat wie schon bei der einführung
des neuen
euro tickets gesagt hat wir haben von
der linkspartei damals wie heute den
satz gehört wir wollen das weiter machen
alles muss quasi umsonst sein wir hören
von den grünen eine historische
entscheidung im nebensatz die für drei
monate gilt was uns danach die fdp
erklärt hat sie haben vom sozialismus
und der reichsbahn geredet und also
sauber so die debatte ist schon die
frage inwieweit es heute wirklich was
gebracht hat ich möchte
ich möchte mich an der stelle mal ganz
bewusst mit den zahlen beschäftigen die
wir schon hören unabhängig von dem ob
wir das ticket gut finden oder ob wir es
schlecht finden wir haben eine also von
den umfragen die wir kennen
entscheidungen das ticket zu nutzen 71
prozent sagen es ist der preis
39 prozent die flexibilität 40 prozent
der verzicht aufs autofahren und 34
prozent die deutschlandweite gültigkeit
wenn man diese indikatoren einfach mal
rat sieht dann muss man sich die frage
stellen überwacht streiten wir uns
eigentlich in diesem haus und wir kommen
zum schluss am ende ist es der preis bei
der preis ist die frage die mittel
aufgewendet werden der preis ist die
frage wie es am ende finanziert wird und
was das ganze kostet ihr vorschlag würde
ungefähr 20 milliarden euro kosten weil
wir die zehn millionen euro
regionalisierungsmittel haben auf die
sie das doppelte einfach nochmal darauf
knallen können
dass einiges einmal um das andere ist
immer wenn wir uns die mittel
aufwendungen anschauen sind wir bei der
frage wem das etwas bringt und wir haben
halt jetzt einfach die situation es ist
keine kritik daran dass es für
urlaubsfahrten genutzt wird dass viele
menschen den urlaub fahren es machen für
den normalen pendler der im ländlichen
raum wohnt ist die entlastung halt
gering das ist einfach eine feststellung
von tatsachen
das ist eine feststellung von tatsachen
das zweite ist wir haben ein team etwas
ja belegen
möchten sie inzwischen fragen zu lassen
oder hin bitte sehr
vielen dank für die zwischenfrage aber
mehr geht eine sache leider ist es auch
ein bisschen davon zeige das hat er noch
gesagt sind im raum wien bringt was und
so weiter und dass es defizite gibt das
wissen wir völlig unabhängig davon was
ein ticket kostet aber es gibt auch
menschen in der bundesrepublik
deutschland die haben keinen
führerschein die leben vielleicht mehr
städten als im ländlichen raum auch den
bringt vielleicht nicht unbedingt was
dass es ein tank rabatt an den
tankstellen kind deswegen würde ich
wirklich mal von ihnen einfach mal
bitten es war ja eine reaktion innerhalb
der koalition die erste idee war ja
völlig nachvollziehbar wir müssen
irgendwie an die spritpreise hat der fdp
gefällt die federführung gehabt
daraufhin haben die grünen reagierten
haben gesagt wir müssen dann als
ausgleich wesen was beim öffentlichen
verkehr machen aber ihre debatte zu
sagen in dem fall gibt es ein teil der
bevölkerung hin bringt das nur ein euro
ticket etix da sage ich nur entgegen es
gibt auch ein teil der bewogen den liter
tank rabatt nix wo unabhängig der frage
ob überhaupt was bringt
die frage von thomas nutzer
den die ampel eingeführt hat zu
verteidigen wo der durchaus ambivalent
diskutieren kann bei der frage was denn
tatsächlich beim einzelnen draußen
wirklich ankommt wenn ich über den
ländlichen raum rede und die frage
bringt das nur ein euro ticket was dann
stellt sich mir die frage was muss man
machen um den öpnv im ländlichen raum
attraktiver zu machen und den macht man
eben nicht über den preis
tiefer die grundfrage im ländlichen raum
ist nicht was kostet der bus sondern
fährt überhaupt ein gewichtiger
einsätzen im ländlichen raum sie müssen
sich in erster linie mal daran
orientieren wie ich eine andere taktung
hinbekomme wie ich eine bessere
vernetzung des öpnv aus hinbekomme und
es gibt zig projekte in ganz deutschland
und in verschiedenen bundesländern wo
man einfach sieht dass mehr mittel die
eingesetzt werden auch erfolgreich sind
und das ist das wo in dem fall
tatsächlich der ländliche raum davon
profitieren würden
wenn wir den öpnv attraktiver machen
wollen
ist nach unserer festen überzeugung
nicht die anfangs frage was der pnv
kostet sondern am ende ist es die
anfragen
pnv muss innovativer werden öpnv muss
vernetzter werden und vor allen dingen
braucht der öpnv auch eine bessere
taktung dass es beispiele dafür gibt das
wissen wir eigentlich alle wer aus baden
württemberg kommt kann seit über vier
jahren des bw ticket nutzen das ist ein
ticketsystem wo du überall im land mit
einem ticket fahren kannst das ist
flexibler in bayern wird klar etwas ganz
ähnliches eingeführt was aber auf
digitalisierung setzt dass du endlich
die möglichkeit hast mit einer app alles
zu buchen überall hinzufahren und vor
allen dingen zu sehen welche verspätung
habe ich denn unabhängig von dem wo die
einzelnen verkehrsträger herkommen wir
haben in nordrhein-westfalen gratis
situation dass man bei den s bahn
verbindungen auf einen 15 minuten takt
umsteigen will das ist gelebte mobilität
in der fläche in münchen wird das
gleiche bei dem s bahn aus nächsten im
20 minuten takt diskutiert und es gibt
zahlreiche beispiele im ländlichen raum
wo man versucht das problem über on
demand verkehr zu nutzen die zielsetzung
für uns muss sein dass der öpnv als
erstes besser wird und danach reden wir
über den preis
danach können wir uns über 1 300 finden
sich sido ticket und behaupten euro
ticket oder 1 0 euro ticket werden pnv
werden pnv starken will der muss an die
taktung ran weil das ist die eigentliche
entscheidung wie man mehr menschen im
ländlichen raum einfach zum umstieg auf
den öpnv
bewegen kann ich habe
gestern eine aktuelle umfrage gesehen
wo gefragt worden ist würden sie denn
nachdem das neun euro ticket ab lauft
weiter den öpnv nutzen
da beim 23 umfrage es vom deutschen
verkehrsforum 23% umschlag
unentschlossenen 26 prozent sagen ja
oder ja
51 prozent sagen nein und nein auf
keinen fall liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich glaube es muss der
gemeinsame ansatz dieses hauses sein
dass die 51 prozent davon überzeugt
werden den öpnv langfristig zu nutzen
weil wir viel geld investiert haben in
der vergangenheit und weil unsere
gemeinsame zielsetzung sein muss dass
wir auch in zukunft deutlich mehr mittel
in den öpnv finanzieren beim stecken wir
haben vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
wie kann der öffentliche nahverkehr
finanzierbar sein und gut zugänglich
auch das ist natürlich ein thema in der
debatte ist henrike michaels ihn spricht
jetzt sehr geehrte kolleginnen dass neun
euro ticket hab jetzt schon alle
erwartungen übertroffen mehr als 30
millionen menschen haben es in den
letzten wochen gekauft die bahn zählt im
schnitt 20 bis 30 prozent mehr fahrgäste
fast 90 prozent der nutzer innen sind
begeistert und mehr als zwei drittel
aller befragten finden gut dass es ein
solches angebot gibt und
in den letzten wochen sind tatsächlich
weniger staus in den städten gemessen
wurden es ist also offenbar zumindest in
ansätzen gelungen menschen vom auto in
den öpnv zu locken das ist ein sehr
wesentlicher grund ja die voraussetzung
dafür über einen nachfolger angebot
nachzudenken
und es stimmt neben dem zeit macht auch
die einfachheit das ticket so beliebt
endlich können verbundgrenzen überfahren
werden allzu oft wohnen und arbeiten
menschen an orten die eben nicht im
selben kreis liegen und sie finden sich
in zwei tarifsystemen wieder deren
kombination kompliziert und finanziell
unattraktiv ist jetzt können sie mit
einem ticket unterwegs sein was für ein
gewinnen
durch das 9 euro ticket ist der öpnv
aber auch in der gesellschaftlichen und
übrigens auch in der politischen debatte
so sehr in die öffentlichkeit gerückt
die vielleicht niemals zuvor landauf
landab haben menschen über das öpnv
angebot vor ort diskutiert bisher
unbekannte verbindungen entdeckt neue
wege ausprobiert landauf landab haben
menschen aber auch festgestellt dass das
angebot ihre bedarf in nicht abbildet
und erinnere auch noch mal daran wer in
den letzten 16 jahren für das
verkehrsministerium verantwortlich war
dass sie mit dem neuen euro ticket in
den nachbarlandkreis fahren könnten die
bahn aber nicht hin fährt dass sie mit
dem neuen euro ticket von der arbeit
nach hause fahren könnten der bus am
abend aber nicht kommt dass ihre kinder
mit dem neuen euro ticket die freundin
besuchen könnten es aber außer dem
schulbus kein anderer gibt die umfragen
zeigen nämlich auch warum viele menschen
das ticket nicht gekauft haben
umständliche verbindungen lange fahrt
dauern oder unpassende abfahrtszeiten
lassen den pnv eben keine attraktive
alternative sein und wenn es kein
passendes angebot gibt nützt auch ein
günstiges ticket nichts deshalb sind
investitionen in den öpnv so dringend
nötig und dürfen durch die finanzierung
von günstigen tickets keinesfalls
ausgebremst oder gar verhindert werden
genau das genau das ist aber ja bei dem
neuen euro ticket auch nicht passiert
das geld kam nämlich zur erinnerung für
alle aus dem entlastungspaket und eben
nicht aus dem gekämpft hat
und die kollegin nikki slavik hat sehr
viele gute vorschläge gemacht woher geld
für beides für tickets und für den
ausbau kommen kann denn wir müssen
beides machen muss ein attraktives
ticket system das im preis und
einfachheit überzeugt und ein angebot
das eben nicht an verbundgrenzen den
abendstunden oder am wochenende endet
sondern die bedarfe der menschen
aufnimmt dann kann aus dem öpnv wirklich
ein rückgrat der verkehrswende werden
nicht weniger als das haben wir uns in
der ampel vorgenommen packen wir es an
vielen dank
matthias kleinert ist noch das wort für
die spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger das neue euro
ticket ist ein wahrlich erfolg wir haben
21 millionen menschen die das erste mal
wahrscheinlich ein monatsticket gekauft
haben und wir haben zehn millionen
menschen die ein abo haben und jetzt für
neun euro für eine deutliche entlastung
glück mein kollege
martin kröger hat das wirklich sehr gut
dargestellt was wir an dieser stelle
entlastet haben und das ist etwas was
uns sozialdemokraten glaube ich bewegt
meine kollegin duo martin hat gesagt wir
müssen einfacher werden an dieser stelle
mit dem neuen euro ticket das glaube ich
eine riesengroße herausforderung
und wir haben das als sozialdemokraten
sowohl in der koalition mit der cdu/csu
braun vielen anderen bereichen wirklich
gepackt dass wir die
regionalisierungsmittel erhöht haben
dass wir die gemeinde
verkehrsfinanzierung mittel erhöht haben
und ich glaube als wesentlicher baustein
fehlt hier tatsächlich auch noch die
verantwortung der länder an dieser
stelle wir dürfen nicht vergessen die
ticketpreise ist keine sache des
deutschen bundestages sondern das ist in
unserem föderalismus drin und ich glaube
da sind sehr viele verantwortungen
tatsächlich auch da und ich glaube
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir diesen
takt haben mit den bundesländern mit den
verkehrsverbünden dass wir hier an
dieser stelle auch noch mal den druck
ausüben und sagen liebe leute diesen
erfolg der bürgerinnen und bürger
müssten wir gemeinsam umsetzen und nicht
der deutsche bundestag der deutsche
kanzler oder auch der verkehrsminister
alleine ist es an dieser stelle sondern
wir müssen dieses an dieser stelle auch
gemeinsam anpacken und ich weiß gerade
bei den menschen die im verkehrsverbund
gearbeitet haben die dort im backoffice
gearbeitet haben für die war das
wirklich eine herausforderung dieses 9
euro ticket umzustellen eine
herausforderung im verwaltungsbereich
und da sage ich auch nochmal ganz
herzliches dankeschön weil das war keine
einfache operation dass die sozusagen
das die die abos haben dann künftig auch
nur noch neun euro bezahlen gleichzeitig
möchte ich mich aber auch bei all
denjenigen bedanken die tagtäglich dafür
kämpfen dass der pnv funktioniert bei
den busfahrerinnen und busfahrern bei
den lokführerinnen und lokführer bei all
denjenigen die diese infrastruktur
aufrechterhalten denn die machen diesen
pnv an dieser stelle nötig möglich und
können auch dafür sorgen dass
bürgerinnen und bürger zuverlässig dann
auch dort ankommen wo sie ankommen ich
hoffe dass auch viele von ihnen
vielleicht auch mal dass neun euro
ticket nutzen wie es gibt auch viele
möglichkeiten es gibt ob mein kollege
krömer hat das schon mal gemacht dass
wir auch menschen die sich vielleicht
nicht nur die neuen euro leisten können
dass wir als bundestagsabgeordnete
dieses spenden der kollege müller zeigt
jetzt seinen neuen euro ticket ich werde
noch mal einen neuen euro ticket tour
machen ich wünschen ihnen einen schönen
sommer und ich denk daran wir arbeiten
an eine nachfolgelösung und das wird
auch eine sozialdemokratische
handschrift haben und ich wünsche einen
schönen sommer vielen dank
matthias stein war das der letzte redner
hier in dieser ersten debatte zum antrag
der linksfraktion auf eine
anschlussregelung für das neuen euro
ticket dieser antrag wird jetzt in den
verkehrsausschuss überwiesen und dort
weiter beraten und